[ __ ]
male ego okay you got that
i say to tony clean the house
i'm gonna bring back the vanilla fudge
who had a huge hit you keep me hanging
on
which was a supreme song and they did it
in a psychedelic way
i said i'm going to bring back the fudge
they're playing
on i think it's 38th avenue south
there's a a place what's it called susan
where the uh um
military kind of place uh
building like a vfw or something or uh
something like that anyway we're
military you know it's
just a big room so
i go there i follow the drummer carmine
apathy who was in
the movie that you saw i follow him into
the
dra bathroom i'd say i'm michael braun
on stage close
[Music]
and i make the mistake of saying where
do you get your clothes and he said hey
ashbury carnaby street and the village
and i say well this is what we're making
what i have is way better than what he's
wearing i mean way
i said you want to come to our house
after the gig
fine three of the four guys came they
bought everything that remotely fit them
and that we could alter for them and
then they wear it on ed sullivan
which is the show live
sunday night eight to nine
big deal all kind of rock and roll
people played that
gig anyway
now
the public
you know freaks out over the vanilla
fudge the clothes are cool
unbeknownst to me they're on the road
with a new guitar player who's come from
england
named jimi hendrix okay i mean he's from
seattle but
he was in england now he comes to
america he's on the road with them
this is before he explodes
jimmy says to carmine
where'd you get the clothes this is one
sentence carmine says
our friends in florida i didn't know we
were friends meaning
we made clothes for them you know but
we're not hanging out
not that i wouldn't but i'm just saying
he says our friends in florida
i go to see a record producer
on first avenue south
almost to 66th street a guy named phil
gernhardt who produced abraham martin
and john
um snoopy versus the red baron
and stay by
maurice williams and the zodiacs these
are
three huge records i take all the
clothes
i go to his office small office whatever
and i show him the clothes
and he says to me listen i'll tell jimmy
about you but i'm not gonna push
you on to jimmy i don't want to upset
him before the gig is an emotional guy
you know it's nothing to me i'm not
getting anything out of this so
you call me sunday afternoon four
o'clock
sunday afternoon comes it's four o'clock
i
dial his number he picks up the phone he
says michael you're not going to believe
this
jimmy gets off the plane and says where
are the closed people
okay so all i'm saying to you is that
you could say you know in the language
of our time they'd say oh you were in
the right place at the right time
or you know this is just luck or
whatever this is destiny
working out this is just insanity crazy
now we end up making clothes for jimmy
and back to the beginning of what i was
trying to say
and that is that so you have this person
that has a little bit of
creative talent for clothes for art
for two-dimensional art
but that's where his brain is if you say
to him
listen i need you to be my lawyer i
committed this murder here's a million
dollars in cash
yes i'm gonna take your money they're
gonna hang you i got no ability to argue
whatsoever
you know i mean none so
all i'm saying to you i'm accepting how
the game is going
because i'm forced into it jimmy
is saying to me in a letter
anything you come across don't be
hesitant
to make something anything to your fancy
as
long as it's specially made as art
period that's
in the middle of the letter especially
made his art what did he mean by that i
talked to him
you know what he's talking to
this is two humans communicating in
english
but he's got his version of english how
he
calls things i made a shirt for him it's
in life magazine
where i use three squares of velcro in
the letter he says try to match the
color of the sticky type buttons
to the color of the shirt or as close as
possible
the meantime velcro just came out he
never heard the word velcro
for sure it just came out then they only
made it in white
but he called it sticky type buttons
what you and i have on our heads
he calls him ear goggles that's just how
he talks
you understand what i'm saying you
really call him ear goggles
really yeah why could i make this up i
guess not that's pretty [ __ ] amazing
so what i'm saying to you is that
he knew by seeing the clothes that we
showed him in the beginning then we made
him clothes
now we're making clothes for them every
three to four months i'm sending them a
whole wardrobe shirts pants jackets
scarves armbands
now he's writing me letters to this
letter to say
i need more of this i need one and more
unusual sleeves so
at one point
he shows me we're in the sheridan hotel
downtown tampa
it's towards the beginning and he shows
me a sleeve
that instead of being small it's maybe
this big
you know mike he's not playing with a
full deck to pour thing
so how does he cut it are you talking
about yourself yes okay how does he cut
it he cuts it from the armpit
to way out here way this much
you'll see hundreds of pictures on the
net of this
and he's using and then six inch ruffles
along the edge
he's buying this fabric this is silk
chiffon and then
all other kind of silks and stuff but
he's buying this fabric
in saint petersburg and in tampa in the
fancy
ladies fabric store he's walking in with
hair out to his shoulders
into a thing that only women go into men
aren't going to buy fabric
to take the fabric to their seamstress
to make a gown for their whatever party
that they're going to to show off
you